now despite mounting evidence that Joe
Biden did in fact talk with Hunter
repeatedly about their overseas business
dealings President Biden he continues to
lie and deny everything in fact he
doesn't even seem bothered by the
allegations at all according to NBC News
he's telling AIDS not to offer him any
advice about his son Hunter One Source
telling NBC that Biden's message is
simple hands off my family but
accountability is coming earlier today
Hunter sat for a deposition in the
defamation lawsuit being brought against
him by computer repair shop owner John
Paul Mac Isaac here with reaction to all
of this the co-host to the hit show The
Five Judge Jeanine hero
and by the way congrats on the new book
it's called Uh crimes against America
it's scary times it really is all right
so I want to deal with two different
time frame here frames here because
shapley is now making the accusation
that these are the attacker your tax
years before 2017 and 18. this is money
including barisma money that we're now
learning that they believe was funneled
to China and then returned to the bidens
Via Alone
um oh I wonder if interest was paid I
wonder if taxes were paid right but
here's what we know we're dealing with a
lot of money and then I'll get to the
2017-12 okay let me talk about that have
you you know for years since 2018 since
this investigation started everyone kept
saying why is this being slow walked why
is this taking so long I could have
written up the indictment and I've said
this many times before the gun charges
and the tax evasion charges in three and
a half minutes okay the reason they slow
walk this it's not even indictment it's
two misdemeanors and a non-charged gun
case you know that's not even being
charged they're giving him two years to
stay out of trouble and will dismiss it
completely is because they wanted the
statute of limitations to run and they
did and the statute of limitations ran
Ergo he owes no money it back taxes they
hide all of the foreign lobbying all of
the you know lobbying without being
registered all the money laundering all
the organized criminal Enterprise gone
statute of limitations you can't even
look at it shapley said 14-year veterans
spoke to CBS News and John Solomon and
Fox News based on my experience if this
was a small business owner or any other
non-connected individual they would have
been charged with felony account they
Not only would have been charged they
would have served their time in jail and
been out already that's how crazy this
is okay now let's go to the money so Joe
Biden leverages one billion dollars in
Ukraine to get a prosecutor fired when
he's VP right now this is his time his
VP this goes to the heart of the 1023
allegation exactly okay where we have a
credible FBI source that was paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars by the
FBI right all right so he says you're
not getting the billion dollars our
money unless you fire that prosecutor
okay you have six hours to do it son of
a bee they fire him to quote Joe that
says quote okay and then guess what
Hunter continues to be in paid for work
that he admitted on Good Morning America
he had no qualifications for the amazing
part of it is what we are seeing in
action is a president of the United
States all wrapped up in the American
flag dictating that a prosecutor be
fired the prosecutor is investigating
Hunter's business and ironically now
with his 1023 which is unclassified
which Christopher Ray the head of the
FBI didn't even want to give us an
unclassified document makes it clear
that they've got tapes where the guy who
is running the company is saying I'm
giving you 5 million I'm giving your
father five or I'm giving the two of you
five million dollars each and I'm
keeping a tape recording of this because
I want to make sure I get my money's
worth I want those tapes we want those
tapes why is Christopher Ray still the
head of the FBI all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else